well I haven't eaten anything yet today
so this is my breakfast I think my nose
is a kid hell yeah who didn't quite
often actually this is a new if it was
itchy
I like scratching it where's my head my
butt my ding-dong
Oh a hundred percent I still pick my
nose if I'm driving and I'm really bored
I definitely roll it up into a little
ball flick it I either flick it out the
window
I flick it to the passenger seat I'm not
the only one who does that okay I'd
certainly don't eat it yeah yep he's
theatre I think anybody who says they
haven't eaten their boogers is it liar
kids do stuff they they put fingers
places and they taste it they're kind of
saltier remember some dirt oh if you had
dirt before they'll be like revisiting
an old friend so I'm gonna find a booger
now I got a lot of nose hair so this
will probably be easy my nose hairs are
like longer than some babies it feel
like I shouldn't let you watch me
there's no like attractive way to pick
your nose I don't think oh oh about one
I got something oh that's nice
right in the crease oh I try for another
oh that was a good one yeah there's
definitely picking up burger you get
some flavor in this one oh my gosh as a
hair I'm gonna mush them together to
make like one giant one there's like a
Ruby Tuesday a booger actually there's
two the hair isn't it bad what sucks is
it like I have to suck it like it's
cheeto dust now that I'm on camera I
don't feel like doing it okay just no
just one
feel like such an [ __ ] it tastes like
my boogers who knows ya know that's
exactly how I remember it little
aftertaste going there's all very easily
and it has excited my mucus my sinuses
it tastes like the clear gummy bears it
tasted just kind of like a unsweetened
mochi mhm
I went in for a second it wasn't as bad
as I thought it would be I was afraid I
was really kind of nervous it's like
just like salty goo that was fun I
wonder if there's any protein or
anything in that I think it's good that
kids eat boogers um yeah it's a life
experience you definitely need to have
as a kid and if you're still eating
boogers as an adult II make sure no
one's looking I mean it's like it's like
what goes in must come out and then go
back in again picking your nose in
general maybe there shouldn't be such a
big stigma on it you know cuz it's just
the thing we all do it and it tastes
better than like your wax your wax is
really Chris